be careful
miss dinosaurs everywhere and they're
flipping out and killing people no one
scenes were we had so many dinosaurs in
the same frame that we had to make the
frame bigger in this Jurassic world you
will see more dinosaurs than you've ever
seen and all the other Jurassic movies
combined and we're gonna see all the
dinosaurs again and we all lost so much
in the first movie we're gonna have you
hey girl you think what I'm thinking
we have the Mosasaurus we have the tear
engine we have a Baryonyx in this movie
Carnotaurus the carnage horse fights the
sign of Sarah tops gonna Stiggy Molly we
just all love this day more like we have
a brand new genetically modified
dinosaur called the endo Raptor it's a
psychopathic murderous Beast
we're dealing with animatronic dinosaurs
it's so cool and the animatronics are
awesome I think what the fans of the
movie liked is that we still have those
real dinosaurs for the actors to
interact with today's audience still
hanker for practical effects in movies
on this project we're all working
together to make these animals come
alive we were able to create some
hopefully really beautiful connection
between man and beasts and this movie
which dinosaurs everywhere
[Music]
hi my name is Claire Dearing and I'm the
founder of the dinosaur protection group
I wanted to let you know about a new way
to get involved in our costs by adopting
your own dinosaur go to our website and
you can demonstrate your commitment to
these animals in return we'll provide
you with your very own certificate
verifying which specific dinosaur that
you helped save adopt a dino and
together we can save them
you